let's go to teresa from austria
theresa what is going on there hi david
can you hear me
i can i i think we had a problem
connecting last time you called in but
now you're coming in crystal clear yes
i was i am usually not a discord user
and i
just downloaded it for the vice
presidential election
right so i was yeah um
i actually um pretty much wanted to give
you guys a heads up
um i'm really nervous for you
when it comes to the election
[Music]
and actually i wanted to ask do you see
an
end for the electoral college at any
given point because i feel like
due to the electoral college uh the
whole
um idea of democracy is
kind of at risk and is really
susceptible
for corruption and i think amy coney
barrett is
very corrupt i think the whole trauma
administration is to be frank
um in my opinion pence is just a robot
or a puppy to trump so from an
outstanding point
it looks really bad what's going on yeah
well listen the
what you're the republican party
wins elections because of the electoral
college so they don't want to get rid of
it
if we had popular vote in the united
states we would have had
fewer republican presidents so the
republican party is going to fight to
the death to keep the electoral college
i think the best
chance to get rid of it is through
something called the national popular
vote interstate compact i won't go into
it now but it's basically if enough
states decide
to go popular vote in terms of awarding
their elect
electoral votes you de facto have a
national popular vote
um but i think that it will be very
difficult to get rid of the electoral
college
any other way even that way it will be
difficult but we should get rid of it it
is
outdated and it is anti-democratic yeah
and we're allowed to vote with
uh 16 years of age in austria so i think
that would actually
turn around this election a lot because
i feel like the very young voters
yeah would have such a big outcome
in this election or in any election
actually i agree with you teresa
what part of austria are you in i live
in lower australia i'm actually
just like 20 minutes away from vienna
okay i was scheduled to be in austria
in august this past august there's a
beautiful
new non-stop flight from boston to
vienna which has now been cancelled
because of the virus
it all exploded but i was going to be in
vienna i was going to be in salzburg
i was so looking forward to it it'll
have to be some other time
i love boston too i was in au pair
massachusetts actually
no no way and i i loved it it's far more
european than what i would have thought
absolutely absolutely that's especially
what we say to texans we're very
european in boston and they
they just think we're [ __ ] you know
all right theresa thank you so much
great to hear from you
thank you for taking my call my pleasure
all right teresa from austria what a day
what a day